esta barra que tenemos aquí representa
un entero un entero que está coloreado
de morado mi pregunta para ustedes es
cuál de las otras barras y puede que
haya más de una representa un medio
nuestro objetivo es encontrar un medio y
como siempre lo hacemos pausa en el
vídeo y traten de hacerlo por ustedes
mismos ok sí ya tratarán de hacerlo
vamos a trabajar juntos en esto para
pensar en mitades o medios déjenme
dibujar otra barra aquí estoy dibujando
otra barra la estoy tratando de hacer
muy parecida a la que tenemos aquí
y la voy a dividir en dos secciones
iguales y voy a colorear solo una de las
secciones que corresponde a un medio de
esta figura mi intención es que estas
dos partes sean iguales bueno esta parte
de aquí es un medio y la voy a colorear
de morado
ahora ninguna de estas barras están
divididas en medios esta de aquí está
dividida en cuartos esta otra está
dividida en 1 2 3 4 5 en 5 partes o sea
en quintos esta está dividida en 1 2 3 4
5 6 está dividido en sextos y esta está
dividida en tercios lo que debemos hacer
es relacionar un medio con las
diferentes cantidades de estos enteros
que están divididos en varias partes no
solo están divididos en dos partes
iguales éste está dividido en cuatro
partes iguales este en cinco éste en
seis y éste en tres y como podemos hacer
eso bueno lo primero que puedo hacer es
dividir esta barra en cuatro secciones
iguales y lo haré dividiendo las dos
secciones que tengo aquí en dos
secciones iguales así que aquí tengo dos
secciones iguales y aquí tengo otras dos
secciones iguales
entonces esto es lo mismo que un medio
fíjense que no cambie la parte que ya
tenía sombreada solamente la dividí en
las secciones y podemos ver que un medio
es lo mismo que dos partes de estas
cuatro que tenemos aquí un medio es
igual que dos cuartos y cuántos cuartos
tenemos aquí 12 tenemos 2 de 4 y éste es
12 de 4 este es uno 2 de 4 y vemos que
dos cuartos y un medio es lo mismo
estas dos barras son equivalentes y
puede que no sea obvio pero si tomamos
esta sección que tenemos aquí y la
movemos a este lado para que esta parte
esté coloreada y esta no entonces se
verían iguales eso podría ayudarnos a
entender que son equivalentes así que
definitivamente aquí tenemos un medio y
la voy a poner en un rectángulo
ahora vamos a pensar en quintos dejen de
dibujar una barra de este lado y aquí
tenemos tres quintos voy a escribirlo de
una vez aquí tenemos tres sextos y aquí
tenemos un tercio y voy a seguir con
esta barra para colorear tres quintos de
este lado
y la voy a dividir en cinco partes
iguales lo mejor que pueda uno
45 sé que mi dibujo no es perfecto pero
podemos darnos una idea de tres quintos
aquí tenemos 12
y tres quintos y podemos pensar en esta
barra como esta que tenemos aquí pero
con las secciones coloreadas
reacomodadas hacia la izquierda así que
aquí tenemos 1 2 y 3 y podemos ver
claramente que estas tres secciones son
más grandes que un medio si quisiéramos
poner estos tres quintos en esta barra
llegarían por aquí entonces podemos ver
que tres quintos definitivamente no son
lo mismo que un medio ok ahora qué pasa
con tres sextos bueno vamos a pensar en
esto un poco y voy a dibujar otra barra
de este lado y sabemos de antemano que
un medio es la mitad de la barra esta
nueva barra que estoy dibujando la voy a
dividir a la mitad y voy a marcar de
morado un medio y lo que tengo que hacer
ahora es dividir la barra en sextos y lo
voy a hacer dividiendo cada una de estas
secciones en tres partes iguales así que
voy a tener dos veces tres piezas que es
lo mismo que 6
mi barra va a quedar dividida en sextos
déjenme hacer esto estoy dividiendo cada
sección en tres partes iguales y no he
cambiado la parte sombreada que
corresponde a un medio de la barra
entera pero ahora tengo que pensar en
términos de sextos y tengo 123 sextos
que es exactamente lo mismo que un medio
es como si tomáramos estos dos sextos y
nos moviéramos de este lado entonces
veríamos esta barra como esta que
tenemos aquí o como esta entonces esta
barra tiene coloreado de morado un medio
y también la encierra en un rectángulo
ahora qué pasa con un tercio voy a
dibujar otra barra para ver qué pasa con
un tercio y como siempre siéntense con
la libertad de pausar el vídeo y tratar
de hacerlo por ustedes mismos y si ya
entendieron lo que está pasando en este
vídeo entonces no es necesario que lo
vean
ok vamos a dividir nuestra barra en
tercios y aquí tenemos un tercio estamos
hablando de un tercio y vemos claramente
que un tercio es menor que un medio un
medio llegaría más o menos por aquí y un
tercio no llega hasta allá así que un
tercio no es igual que un medio espero
que se hayan divertido